how to stay focused so I got a great
question from one of my youtube viewers
love you guys sohail who wrote in to say
hi thank you for your videos i'm not an
entrepreneur but a researcher and trying
to make a contribution currently doing
my PhD in the field of lexical
engineering i watch your videos as I
hope that started business with the
algorithms I will develop can you give
me some tips for staying focused as in
the field of providing software
solutions to my field there are already
big companies i have a dream but the
reality seems impossible Thanks this is
a great question and the reality is
whether you've already started your
business or you're thinking about doing
it it can be hard to stay focused on
your dream and often when you're not
seeing the momentum and you're not
seeing the progress you're not seeing
the dollars it can beat down on you and
and you may sometimes feel like I'm
never going to reach this I should give
up on this dream and just stay at my job
and be happy I'm going to give you three
suggestions for how to stay focused and
continue to build your business number
one is decide you have to first decide
that this is important to you and that
you're going to make this a business
right because right now you're on the
fence right now you haven't fully
decided you're afraid a lot of the fear
goes away a lot of the uncertainty goes
away once you decide it's a lot like
dating versus getting married okay I
don't know what your relationship status
is but you know when you're when you're
dating somebody you know you meet them a
lot and you have your weekends together
and whatever you're doing you're dating
but it's it's it's a relationship but
it's not committed you know you're not
in you haven't decided once you get
married you know you get down on your
knee you pop that question you've
decided right now you're in this now
there's no going back now there's no
look at other options right you're in it
so that's what you need to do with your
business you need to decide you need to
decide that this is going to be
something important for you and you're
going to take action on it and when you
decide then the options open up the fear
goes away a little bit and you stay
focus on your task so decide
number two is create a schedule one of
the best ways that I know how to stay
focused on my task on my goal is to
create a schedule so this isn't your
full-time thing yet you have a certain
number of hours you dedicated to this
every week I would schedule that time in
that has to be really important time
right and this is for anybody who's
running the business or is doing it part
time you schedule in your CEO timer you
schedule in your task management time
and you don't allow interruptions right
you turn off your phone you know you
lock the door you don't check facebook
you know you don't watch youtube videos
even mine you're not watching my youtube
videos on these times and you sit down
and you work and you know you have this
amount of time every week or every day
to spend on your project and you get to
work so folks vote forces you it forces
you to stay focused on the time so look
at your schedule see how much time you
have and plot it out every week every
day however much time you have and don't
allow for any interruptions during that
time create a schedule number three is
launched quickly one of the hardest
thing to do as an entrepreneur is create
while you're in a vacuum you're creating
by yourself and there's nobody around
you to give you feedback to tell you
what to do to give you suggestions to
say hey what you're doing is great and
when you're just creating alone it can
be discouraging you don't know if you're
making progress or not you don't get the
feed off the energy of other people for
me it's hard to like I'm making these
videos I'm by myself and win a empty
room and I'm just talking to a camera
and what helps keep me going is knowing
that you guys are watching and and
you're leaving your comments and you're
giving me feedback and you're saying
Evan keep going you're saying these are
great videos that is fuel for me right
you need to get your fuel so you want to
launch your algorithms your software
whatever it is as soon as possible
there's a term in the software industry
called Minimum Viable Product where it's
basically don't spend all this time
creating the perfect product create
whatever is just enough that people will
use it because
you get their feedback you start to get
a little bit of market adoption of
people using it and they tell you why
it's good why it's bad we're to fix it
and that that's fuel because now you're
depending on other people right you're
you're providing the something that's
helping them out and that's fuel for you
to do better now you're not just by
yourself and when somebody writes to you
and says while your algorithms really
helped me with my project or my business
or whatever it is that makes you feel so
good that you'll want to keep going or
if somebody says hey I'd love it if your
algorithm could do this it gives you
something to work on and now you're you
have you almost have a boss you have
somebody that you're accountable to that
you have to get this done for and not
just yourself when your ideas and you'll
do it whenever so launch your product
launch your algorithms as quickly as
possible so you start getting feedback
and some fuel so in summary how to stay
focused number one decide number to
create a schedule number three launch
quickly and believe for those who are
watching you liked this video you can
subscribe to the channel you can support
me by clicking on the link in the
description and leave a comment let me
don't you think your comments mean a lot
to me and I love seeing them come in so
thank you so much I'll see you soon